[Música]
muy buenas noches bienvenidos al debate
de france 24 soy santiago lópez gonzález
este 10 de diciembre se cumple un año de
la llegada de alberto fernández a la
presidencia de argentina secundado por
la ex presidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner como fórmula vicepresidencial
fernández heredó un país con una
inflación y una deuda que equivale al 80
y 9.4 por ciento del producto interno
bruto de ese país un año de recesión una
década de estancamiento desempleo al
alza cerca del 40 por ciento de la
población bajo el umbral de la pobreza
sólo tres meses después de haber llegado
al poder la pandemia del cobi 19
complicó aún más las cosas en argentina
y bueno en el mundo entero el
confinamiento la paralización fueron
prácticamente el tiro de gracia para que
las finanzas argentinas tuvieran aún más
un panorama complicado este año 22 mil
empresas han desaparecido en argentina
por cuenta de esta crisis económica
sumada por la pandemia del cob y 19 se
han perdido 3.7 millones de empleos se
prevé también una caída
del 12.9 de su producto interno bruto
pero alberto fernández también se anotó
algunos logros importantes a lo largo de
este año de gestión consiguió un acuerdo
con los acreedores internacionales para
reestructurar la deuda argentina y
evitar así la temida y también muy mal
vista suspensión de pagos este fue una
de sus promesas de campaña y pues ya
acertó en esta negociación eso le dio un
leve respiro al sector económico
argentino también a los ciudadanos y a
las finanzas al menos por un tiempo
también concretó la compra de la vacuna
sputnik vi a rusia para comenzar un plan
de vacunación contra el jove 19 un plan
de vacunación que ya está atrasado y que
le permite dar un respiro en el tema de
la pandemia y comenzar a concretar otras
promesas de campaña como por ejemplo la
legalización de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo a un proyecto
que fue presentado por el propio
presidente y también una reforma
judicial el tema de la interrupción del
embarazo está siendo debatido en el
congreso y es uno de los temas de la
agenda más destacados a lo largo de esta
semana en argentina esto es solamente
por mencionar algunos temas algunos de
los puntos destacados de este
de gestión del presidente fernández allí
en argentina en el siguiente reportaje
les contamos mucho más veamos
hago en un año después entre la
esperanza y la resignación
alberto fernández llegó al poder en
argentina para recuperar la maltratada
economía del país algo que no ha
sucedido a la crisis heredada se sumó la
pandemia del cob y 19 a toda la
argentina a todos los argentinos a todas
las argentinas a partir de la cero hora
de mañana deberán someterse al
aislamiento social preventivo y
obligatorio una respuesta al coronavirus
que empezó siendo admirada pero que lo
ha ido desgastando que sea uno de los
confinamientos más largos del mundo
argentina es el tercer país de américa
latina con más muertes tampoco ha
logrado iniciar la recuperación
económica aunque se han visto sus
intentos de llevar a cabo una política
social con las ayudas de pandemia o una
novedosa ley de impuestos a los ricos
rechazada por la oposición ligada al
presidente macri por los afectados
además del impulso directamente desde
presidencia de la ley de legalización
del aborto enviaré al congreso de la
nación para su tratamiento
dos proyectos de ley para que todas las
mujeres accedan al derecho a la salud
integral un hito de gobierno que
comparte con la reestructuración de la
deuda y la renegociación con el fmi con
la que consiguió extender vencimientos
de pago y reducir las tasas de interés
aunque el problema de la deuda dista de
estar resuelto y que hoy con
tranquilidad podemos decir que el
objetivo que nos fijamos lo hemos
logrado
para la argentina el acuerdo que hemos
alcanzado significan 37 mil 700 millones
de dólares menos que deberemos pagar en
los próximos 10 años en política
internacional este primer año podría dar
lugar a un liderazgo de argentina en
mercosur
fernández se ha acercado al presidente
de brasil their bolsonaro para forjar
alianzas en la región
aunque la oposición lo acusa de haberse
kitchen izado son evidentes las
distancias con la antigua mandataria y
ahora vicepresidenta cristina fernández
de kirchner
bajo cuya sombra ha gobernado este año
2021 servirá para comprobar si se
confirman las expectativas previas a su
elección o bien en los comicios de mitad
de mandato vuelve a haber un giro
político en el país un reto que en buena
medida dependerá de la gestión de la
vacunación que él quiere convertir en
una epopeya porque alberto fernández no
será juzgado tanto por lo que prometió
sino por lo que le tocó como él mismo
dijo somos los gobernantes de la
pandemia y así nos recordarán
y para analizar y para conocer más
detalles sobre este tema saludamos a els
allende de rosa ella es analista
política y directora de ciencia política
de la universidad de buenos aires se
conecta desde la capital argentina y
también está con nosotros
julio burdman él es analista doctor en
ciencia política por el instituto de
estudios políticos de parís es también
profesor de la universidad de buenos
aires también se encuentra en la capital
argentina se unen a esta conversación y
les recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de este diálogo pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales del recuerdo estamos
en facebook y también en instagram y en
twitter france24
s arroba sant y luego mi cuenta personal
el numeral o en la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 y comenzamos y comienzo
con el site y en la ciudad de buenos
aires cuál es el balance global que
usted hace de este primer año de gestión
hay más temas aprobados desaprobados
como dicen ustedes allí en la argentina
muchos temas pendientes en esa agenda de
trabajo cuál es su percepción
bueno buenas noches de santiago lo
cierto es que esa reseña que prepararon
le hace bastante justicia a la
descripción de todo el proceso que vivió
el presidente en fernández durante este
año podríamos decir que el balance en
general es desfavorable de alguna manera
porque la pandemia agudizó los problemas
ya recibidos económicos en una economía
en recesión una la necesidad de
renegociar la deuda con fondos
extranjeros y también ahora con el fondo
monetario internacional pero lo cierto
es que en términos económicos y sociales
la situación que argentina se empeoró
dramáticamente durante este año por
supuesto los efectos de la pandemia han
sido muy muy fuertes decisivos pero
particularmente también la forma de
gestionar del gobierno aplicando unos
confinamientos muy duros y muy
y agudizaron entonces esta situación
económica y social con un problema grave
de aumento de la pobreza y de la pobreza
extrema y de la exclusión y quisiera
mencionar también un tema que nos
preocupa mucho que es el de la educación
porque de la mano de esta de este
confinamiento que se ha suspendido
durante mucho tiempo en las clases
presenciales y las clases virtuales en
el plano primario y secundario realmente
no han podido cumplir verdaderamente con
los objetivos de educación así que
tardamos en un panorama muy complejo en
términos económicos sociales educativos
después podría hablar también del plano
político si es que las circunstancias
que tenía argentinas antes de la llegada
a la pandemia ya eran difíciles era una
situación sobre todo económica muy
complicada julio cuál es su opinión cuál
es el balance global que usted hace de
este primer año de gestión del
presidente fernández
bueno comparto muchas cosas que dijo
elsa es muy difícil hacer un balance
porque le tocó un año muy excepcional y
de hecho recordemos que la pandemia se
declara en marzo y el gobierno en marzo
recién comenzaba a instalarse
de hecho en para marzo no tenía muchos
sus funcionarios aún designados
y también creo que como dijo el saca el
tema central que arrastraba en argentina
tenía que ver con la reestructuración de
la deuda que era un peso muy fuerte no
sólo por la influencia de la deuda sobre
el pib sino también por la cantidad de
vencimientos acumulados que tenía de
argentina para el año 2020 en el marco
de esta pandemia pues no podía hasta
pensar que la pandemia resultó útil para
que la argentina pudiese renegociar la
deuda con un poco más de consideración
por parte de los acreedores y del fondo
monetario internacional por otra parte
creo que se creó una una ilusión de que
argentina estaba combatiendo mejor la
pandemia que otros países
cuando avanza la enfermedad el
coronavirus del cob y 19 en américa
latina
inicialmente argentina tenía mejor
desempeño que brasil y que otros países
de la región y es una suerte de motivo
de orgullo para el presidente fernández
éramos como un país modelo supuestamente
en el combate de la pandemia pero
finalmente los números argentinos se
fueron pareciendo cada vez más de los
otros países de hecho son peores aún
ahora que los de muchos otros países y
esto también genera una suerte de
sensación de balance negativo porque de
alguna
argentina tenía un mejor desempeño que
otros países de la región en materia de
cómic 19 se parecía que buena parte de
las variables que iban hacia abajo las
socioeconómicas las financieras la de
nivel de actividad se veían de alguna
forma compensada por el éxito sanitario
lamentablemente esto no fue así julio ya
que usted menciona el tema de la
pandemia y el manejo que le ha dado el
gobierno de fernández a esta situación
hay en argentina
en este tema y sigo con usted y luego
paso a darle la palabra a elsa solo por
poner en contexto algunas de las cifras
argentinas es el noveno país a nivel
mundial con la mayor cantidad de casos
un millón 482 mil casos registrados al
día de hoy y 40 mil 200 personas han
perdido la vida por causa del cob y 19
estos son números que arroja el conteo
de la universidad johns hopkins que es
uno de los mayores conteos a nivel
internacional
como lo decía usted julia el principio
argentina era visto como un país que
estaba manejando relativamente bien el
tema de la pandemia pero pronto se
empezó a ver la cuarentena más larga del
mundo una prolongación de este
confinamiento al parecer por una escasez
de ideas de qué hacer con la situación
de la pandemia pero también hay que
recordar que fernández recibió un país
que no tenía ministerio de salud cuando
empezó la pandemia
en argentina como evalúa entonces
profundizamos en ese tema de la pandemia
de alguna forma en el año 2020 terminado
demostrando que no había muchas
soluciones mágicas al manejo de la
pandemia no había muchas fórmulas
alternativas creo que argentina en los
países de américa la tiene de generar a
los países europeos también han tenido
todos el problema de cómo administrar
las expectativas de la población y las
conductas de la población en una suerte
de balance rápido pareciera que los
países que mejor pudieron administrar
estos son los que tenían mayor capacidad
de encontrar a la población y sus
fronteras que no es el caso en las
democracias de europa y de américa
latina por lo tanto de alguna forma la
argentina con su cuarentena extendida a
sus
sus enfoques aparentemente más fuertes
que otros países hizo un intento de
un potro alternativo o digamos más
estricto más ortodoxo
y la realidad te vio demostrando que yo
no tenía tanta tanto utilidad porque el
resultado finalmente convergieron con
los de brasil y méxico que eran los
países que habían encarado de este forma
un poco más flexible por lo tanto bueno
nos queda ese sabor amargo no que
argentina invirtió de base o de esfuerzo
en la población argentina invirtió
demasiado esfuerzo y mucho sacrificio y
los resultados finalmente fueron
bastante mediocres para varios si el sas
opinión al respecto al balance en el
manejo de la pandemia que es tal vez el
siguiente tema después de hacer frente a
la situación económica
sí sin duda las primeras medidas del
presidente fernández recibirán un alto
nivel de aprobación y acompañamiento
incluso de los partidos de la oposición
el problema es que esta pandemia esta
medida de confinamiento iniciales que se
tomaron se anunciaron con el objetivo de
mejorar la capacidad sanitaria a mejorar
la adquisición de suministros médicos
para enfrentar la pandemia pero luego no
encontró un camino o una roca de ruta de
salida de la cuarentena y se extendió
demasiado y verdaderamente está la
cuarentena tendría que haber sido
acompañada con medidas de testeo rastreo
detección de contactos y aislamiento un
plan mucho más complejo que no se aplicó
que evidentemente habrá que replantear
para futuras olas o rebrotes que
aparezcan por delante y que luego
terminó como comparto con lo que decía
julio terminó con una cantidad de
infectados de contagios y de muertos
terminaron verdaderamente colocando
argentinas entre los en el podio de los
países con con peor desempeño frente a
la pandemia sea que esa aprobación
inicial y ese acompañamiento inicial que
verdaderamente terminó en una situación
en la que hoy el presidente fernández
esta verdad que está más cuestionado y
es desaprobada es una opinión en la
percepción negativa por encima del
respaldo en términos del manejo de la
pandemia y éstos están observando bien
la opinión pública
complementó lo que ustedes dicen y estas
cifras que ustedes mencionan al 20 de
marzo que fue el día que fue anunciado
la orden de confinamiento a nivel
nacional el presidente alcanzó un 80 por
ciento de popularidad por estas medidas
que estaba instaurando para hacer frente
a la pandemia al día de hoy la
aprobación es sólo el 50 por ciento que
igual es una aprobación alta comparada
con muchos mandatarios de américa latina
y un 47 por ciento de desaprobación
frente a las medidas
adoptado y muchas personas le cobran una
suerte de doble discurso porque mientras
el presidente pedía que las personas se
quedaran en su casa que utilizaran
mascarillas y que evitaran salir hubo
algunos escenarios en los que se le veía
el presidente reunido con otros
políticos sin usar la mascarilla luego
vino este funeral de diego armando
maradona donde claramente pues la
situación se salió de control y fue muy
criticado por el manejo que se le dio y
mucha gente se lo ha cobrado en su
aprobación de gestión viviendo un poco
otros temas
destacados de este año de gobierno y
saliendo me un poco de las fronteras
argentinas llamaba mucho la atención la
fórmula vicepresidencial que tiene
alberto fernández muchas personas
pensaban que él simplemente iba a
gobernar en la sombra de cristina
fernández que ya lo decimos pues gobernó
este país y su esposo también fue
presidente de argentina que tanto se ha
desmarcado el presidente de la
vicepresidenta que tanto ha gobernado de
forma autónoma o que tanto ha tenido que
estar simplemente
marcando desmarcándose algunos temas
dependiendo de la opinión de cristina
comienzo con julio
yo creo que la relación entre cristina
fernández y alberto fernández que no son
parientes es una relación que se
presenta misteriosa para la comunidad
política argentina e internacional
porque hay una novedad cristina kirchner
sin dudas es la líder del espacio
político
libre
y alberto fran es el presidente que en
argentina en un país presidencialista
como argentina implican tener el poder
constitucional e institucional de su
lado no obstante cristina tiene una
característica peculiar esto este
periodo y es que no ha hablado mucho
toda la trayectoria de ella del siglo 21
se había caracterizado por que yo tenía
una voz muy fuerte en la política
argentina y sus intervenciones en él
realmente gravitantes en todo este
periodo hay una suerte de gran cuestión
acerca de cuánto influye la ex
presidente de actual vicepresidenta y
cuál es su real
incidencia en las políticas públicas del
gobierno es muy difícil determinar esto
el presidente insiste que él es el líder
del gobierno la propia cristina también
asegura hace poco en algunas
intervenciones que la responsabilidad
son otras todas las medidas en el
presidente alberto fernández y yo tiendo
a creerle un poco a esa a esa
descripción yo creo que efectivamente
cristina kirchner está a un costado de
la decisión en la mayor parte de los
temas por propia decisión porque ella
era consciente que el gobierno de
alberto fernández iba a ser un gobierno
complejo en materia económica y
financiera que involucra un conjunto de
medidas de ajuste y christina se quería
ver alejada de todo eso no es su función
y su rol en la política argentina
encabezar un gobierno de augusto o de
austeridad
sin embargo hay una enorme incertidumbre
acerca de siendo realmente es así o no
pero yo tiendo a querer que cristina
kirchner tiene otros planes en la
política argentina y no tiene la
intención de intervenir en la toma de
decisión de política pública para este
periodo además que en ciertos escenarios
conviene un poco desmarcarse sobre todo
porque la vicepresidenta está siendo
cuestionada por la justicia argentina en
diferentes aspectos
elsa su opinión sobre esta relación
misteriosa entre
presidente y vicepresidenta
y queda cuestionada un poco por ser de
pronto un gobierno en las sombras pero
tal parece que la situación no es tan
así
es una convivencia muy difícil estaba
rodeada de tensiones está rodeada de
contradicciones y lo que vimos en este
año de gestión es que el presidente
fernández no ha podido construir un
poder propio es decir un poder que no
dependa del apoyo del respaldo de la
presidenta ese margen de maniobra que
inicialmente podía tener un presidente
en un sistema presidencialista lo que
vemos es que aparece permanentemente
condicionado contra es de alguna manera
aparecen decisiones legislativas que van
contra los planes del propio presidente
correcciones que se hacen en el congreso
por la propia fuerza oficialista a
proyectos que presenta el propio
presidente es decir hoy lo que veo es un
sistema político donde
fuerza la coalición que constituye el
oficialismo está en plena atención en
plena contradicción dentro de sus
propias líneas
y fuerzas políticas internas y esa
convivencia es muy compleja está
trabando la gestión política está
trabajando la gestión de políticas
públicas está trabajando las
negociaciones importantes que hacen a
decisiones muy muy importantes para la
economía y la política argentina y lo
que veo es una es una convivencia que
como digo es muy completa y que cada vez
ha llevado al presidente fernández a
como escuela cristianizarse de alguna
manera no a kirchner y satse se está
recortando cada vez más en la narrativa
en el discurso en pos particularmente en
posiciones por ejemplo en política
exterior donde su su perfil
su política
está alejada de lo que inicialmente
podría asociarse con los postulados de
alberto fernández se acerca mucho más a
ese sector interno que representa muy
fuertemente que tiene mucho peso
determinante de cristina' panamá
kirchner sigo con algunos de los temas
de política interna antes de hablar de
la relación de argentina con sus vecinos
y con otros países de la región
elsa vemos que por ejemplo hoy está
siendo debatido en el congreso argentino
esta ley de la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo un tema que divide
profundamente a la sociedad argentina ha
provocado el surgimiento de movimientos
sociales que han salido a las calles
tanto a favor como en contra de esta
propuesta y también una ley de justicia
como ve usted estos dos proyectos que
están tratando de hacer trámite el
presidente en el congreso dos ases bajo
la manga como los ve usted
en principio los veo como dos proyectos
de naturaleza social distinta
de algún área de llegada a intereses de
movimientos sociales como bien dijiste
recordemos que la ley de interrupción
legal del embarazo había sido votada
hace dos años había sido aprobada en
cámara diputados pero fue rechazada en
el senado o sea que esto se corresponde
con una demanda social muy fuerte en la
sociedad argentina que por supuesto
tiene también sus sus opositores pero
hay una ola verde muy fuerte por
conseguir este derecho para las mujeres
y de alguna manera esto lo tomó el
presidente fernández en su campaña fue
muy muy claro en defender esta postura
es una promesa de presentar este
proyecto
y eventualmente si es aprobado como se
supone que desaprobó se aprobará en el
día de mañana y luego en el senado
pasaría a ser verdaderamente un gran
logro de su gestión una promesa cumplida
sería de su gestión
en cambio la reforma judicial si vienen
en la campaña electoral el presidente
fernández había hablado de una reforma
del funcionamiento de la justicia
verdaderamente los proyectos que se
están discutiendo no no coinciden con la
perspectiva que inicialmente había
planteado el presidente fernández de
hecho la propia vicepresidenta cuestionó
incluso algunas y algunos de estos
proyectos orientados entonces yo
como dos ámbitos y dos temáticas
distintas en términos de llegada a la
sociedad y de apoyo y respaldo social y
político de la fuerza política
julio en torno a esta ley de justicia el
presidente fernández hablando sobre la
justicia argentina decía que en algunas
de sus intervenciones a lo largo de este
año decía que la justicia argentina no
estaba marchando muy bien pero también
vemos que la vicepresidenta del país
está siendo investigada por diferentes
casos
yo no podría ir dentro de las teorías de
conspiración pensar muchas cosas el
referente a esta ley de de renovación de
la justicia que piensa usted
en primer lugar alberto fernández en
toda su campaña presidencial fue muy
cauto en materia de promesas realmente
dijo muy pocas cosas e inclusive cuando
era sube la presidencia hace un año
también asumido diciendo muy poco él era
consciente que le tocaba un gobierno muy
difícil justicia fue uno de los pocos
temas de los que habló el prometió una
reforma judicial y como decía esa
tendiente a la modernización y la
transparencia algunos procesos y
procedimientos sobre todo la justicia
del ámbito federal que en la que tiene
que ver con los principales
el principal volumen de causas que
inclusive muchas de las cuales afectan
muchas veces la relación entre poderes
ahí da la impresión yo no soy un gran
conocedor de estos pasillos profundos de
los temas judiciales de hecho en mi
opinión no debería ser el tema principal
de la argentina en este momento tan
dramático en términos sociales y
económicos para mí es un tema que podría
esperar tranquilamente pero bueno hay un
compromiso de fernánde con este tema que
creo que lo hace como propio y además me
da la impresión que cristina kirchner
también tiene una agenda distinta a las
esperanzas en este punto hasta
este escenario planteado el presidente
logre llevar el proyecto en alianza con
algunos sectores de la oposición porque
tiene buen diálogo
y no está con el respaldo de la propia
presidenta ahora que hicieron que
hiciera un comentario sobre la ley de
interrupción del embarazo claro pero
antes tan seguro como esa que esto sea
un espacio tan cómodo para el presidente
fernández
porque él es cierto que ha impulsado
esto y es cierto que el movimiento de
mujeres y un movimiento favorable a la
aprobación del aborto legal que es muy
importante pero también hay muchas
posiciones en argentina y buena parte de
sus posiciones está dentro del propio
partido justicialista y el propio la
propia coalición gobernante uno de los
principales riesgos que enfrenta el
presidente a mi juicio es la posibilidad
de que su coalición sufra turbulencias
internas más allá de la cuestión con las
vicepresidentas y no aunque haya digamos
decepción por parte de votantes o de
aliados locales al presidente fernández
por lo tanto hay una verdad de paradoja
y el presidente fernández logra aprobar
este proyecto va a ser un logro personal
ahora al mismo tiempo puede ser una
fuente de tensiones no hay una sola
vieron detalle el papá francisco es
argentino tiene mucho vínculo con ese
partido peronista y con muchos muchos
sectores dentro de la condición
oficialista y el papel de en contra este
proyecto por lo tanto yo creo que
también ahí fue ahí
algunos factores de tensión alrededor de
la cuestión de la oportunidad claro
julio en términos de política exterior
algunos analistas han calificado este
año de política exterior de alberto
fernández al mando argentina como un
poco errática porque se le ve condenado
a nicolás maduro en el consejo de
derechos humanos de las naciones unidas
en ginebra pero luego lo absuelve en la
organización de estados américanos y
evitan por uno es un momento mencionar o
dar algún tipo de punto de vista en
torno a las elecciones parlamentarias de
venezuela que es tal vez la crisis
política más difícil que está viviendo
américa latina y por eso concierne la
opinión de los otros estados cuál es su
opinión
yo creo que el presidente francés está
se propuso inicialmente un perfil
distinto en américa del sur y américa
latina él quería hacer una suerte de
punto medio entre bolsonaro y maduro y
de hecho creo que la cuestión de
venezuela él buscó ese punto medio
inicialmente bajo la suposición de que
iba a poder formar junto con méxico y
con uruguay una suerte de polo a mitad
de camino entre el grupo de lima y el
sector maduro del grupo de lima
va vinculado con el presidente de trump
con funcionario y con el presidente de
duke de de colombia y por otro lado los
países del alba que apoyan
incondicionalmente a maduro soy ahora me
parece que argentina no encontró un
lugar intermedio finalmente porque
méxico tiene una posición propia
abstencionista en todo tipo de
conflictos porque siguen la doctrina
tradicional estrada de la diplomacia
mexicana y en uruguay un cambio de
gobierno por lo tanto tampoco encuentra
ahí una suerte de aliado para esa
búsqueda de la posición intermedia por
lo tanto creo que tiene quedó
descolocada frente a la cuestión de
venezuela e inclusive no logró ni ni ni
los instrumentos para mostrar ese punto
intermedio ni tampoco la narrativa
adecuada por eso creo que argentina en
la cuestión de venezuela se determina un
poco desubicada
y elsa su opinión me queda un poco más
de un minuto y medio para finalizar el
programa su opinión en torno a la
política exterior
es quizás una de las políticas públicas
más que más se mostó la de la mente
errática conflictiva con muchos
problemas hacia adentro de la coalición
de gobierno piensen que por ejemplo el
presidente de la cámara de diputados
sergio massa llama al gobierno de maduro
verdaderamente con una dictadura
mientras que de otras salas del gobierno
tienen lazos muy estrechos y cercanos
con el presidente maduro y esto hace que
este juego hacia dentro de la coalición
ha dejado al presidente y al ejecutivo y
a la cancillería argentina en una
posición incómoda donde muestra mensajes
contradictorios como muy bien lo señaló
julio y lograría que la gestión de la
política exterior ha sido verdaderamente
uno de los de los puntos más
problemáticos sólo mencionó que por
ejemplo la campaña fácil
de argentina por promover al presidente
del bid de gustavo béliz en esa
presidencia donde no reunió apoyos de
países vecinos de la región en esa
gestión sumaría también el mal comienzo
en la relación con el presidente
bolsonaro y con el propio presidente
lacalle pou de uruguay relaciones que
afortunadamente ahora se están
reconvirtiendo y que se están retomando
consigo en algunas comunicaciones y
sumaría también el rechazo inicial que
el gobierno mostró al acuerdo del
mercosur y la unión europea y también el
rechazo a que el mercosur siguiera
negociando por los comerciales que
tenían la agenda entonces hay una serie
de contradicciones sigue verdaderamente
concluye el año con mucha dificultad es
bastante desfavorable también a elsa y a
julio la ciudad de buenos aires les
agradezco por habernos acompañado en
esta edición del debate de france 24
gracias por habernos acompañado y
ustedes también gracias por dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales siga con nuestra
programación buenas noches
[Música]